ce dernier bonsoir merci bonsoir c'est
vrai que j'étais bernier en beauce et
oui ça va bien mais monsieur harper aime
la majorité c'était la plus grande
majorité à l'extérieur de l'alberta
parce que partout avec sur l'alberta les
consommateurs en alberta gang par 60%
des votes
à l'époque je pense j'en ai gagné par
soit 117 pour ça mais ça c'est du passé
ou est-ce qu'aujourd'hui mais juste
parce que je vais vous ramener dans le
passé un petit peu au mois de mai 2017
on va voir des images vous n'êtes pas
assez il faut le rappeler aux gens je
veux devenir le chef du parti
conservateur du canada
on voit une douche r vous êtes à côté
voulu féliciter vous avez eu 49 % des
voix il ya eu plusieurs tout et c'est à
toronto
ma question monsieur bernier pis une
question où j'ai depuis plusieurs mois
depuis deux jours gare d'allé si vous
étiez devenu chef du parti conservateur
est ce que vous auriez développer les
mêmes positions beaucoup plus extrême
que vous développez actionnaires mais je
sais pas qu'est ce que vous entendez par
extrême les positions économiques c'est
des vrais positions conservatrices
durant la course au leadership je
prônais pour les clés budgétaire mais
même rougir fait ça un brushing est
qu'elle est balancé deux le budget à
l'équilibré par dont le budget en deux
ans et maintenant il changé d'avis comme
vous savez ça va être seulement qu'en
cinq ans nous on a la même position mais
ce que les gens disent et là vous
arrêter on va aller là vos politiques
nous aurait été le même maxime bernier
pouvant insulté great haletante bulles
pouvant dire les changements climatiques
c'est pas sérieux vous auriez tu es le
meilleur ou à la tête du parti
conservateur du canada j'ai les mêmes
convictions que j'avais à l'époque et le
changement climatique faut en parler ce
que je déplore c'est cette frénésie
d'urgence climatique et j'aime pas que
les gens disent que bernier est un
climato sceptiques c'est une insulte
c'est pas vrai le climat change club
maintenant vous croyez au changement qui
moi j'ai toujours cru au changement
jamais dit que le co2 c'était pas de la
pollution six mois répondre à vos
questions j'ai toujours cru au
changement climatique
j'ai dit que contrairement aux autres
policiers que la raison principale que
les changements climatiques ont lieu ce
n'est pas la raison principale
l'activité humaine sur la terre
l'activité humaine sur la terre pu être
un facteur mais parmi tant d'autres et
c'est ça la grosse cinq distinctions
entre moi et les autres politiciens et
je dis faut être honnête avec la
population parce que lorsque monsieur
trudeau lorsque monsieur chiffres
parlent de changement
climatique tous ces politiciens là
disent qu'ils vont s'assurer de
respecter l'entente de paris est
d'atteindre les cibles mais tout le
monde le sait en commençant par
elizabeth may que c'est impossible avec
une taxe sur le carbone de 32,50 dollars
la tonne donc ils sont hypocrites envers
la population très bien mais vous faites
quand même combat contre la science là
parce que quand vous dis non
l'activité humaine est peut-être un
facteur est remise aux scientifiques et
plusieurs scientifiques germaneau mais
j'ai même un consensus scientifique
monsieur bernier mais c'est l'activité
humaine qui causent les changements
climatiques jem a nommé patrice moore
qui était un des fondateurs du mouvement
greenpeace et qui pensent comme ça
bientôt et quand vous parlez de
consensus scientifique la science
n'avance pas par consensus c'est la
politique les consensus et politique la
science avance par la raison par l'effet
est jugé m
et oui mais je peux je suis d'accord
avec vous que quelques scientifiques qui
quelques heures quelques scientifiques
qui sont d'accord avec la position que
je prends et d'autres essais en minorité
bcgo n'essaie pas de point de vue c'est
votre point mais je leur ai s'il est
mathématiquement mais le gia qui rêvent
tous les grands je vous dis c'est que je
suis d'accord avec lui sur les
changements climatiques où je ne suis
pas d'accord avec eux c'est qu'on doit
changer notre mode de vie qu'on doit
tous bouleversés qu'on doit changer et
même des gens qui disent qu'on doit
arrêter d'avoir des enfants cause des
changements climatiques c'est ça que je
trouve irresponsable et on fait peur aux
gens et moi la panique ce n'est pas à la
base politique noble et qu'est-ce que
vous prônez vous êtes il n'y a pas
d'urgence
on continue pom pom pom tout va bien non
je dis que les hommes et comme comme ils
ont fait le libre marché
la science humaine va trouver des
solutions pour améliorer l'environnement
et les changements climatiques
regardez les voitures électriques sap a
été inventé par les émissions bien je ne
faut pas réduire la pauvreté humaine
ce que je dis les émissions par le
développement technologique les
émissions vont diminuer comme ils l'ont
fait dans le passé
l'avancement de la technologie à faire
en sorte qu'on ait des techniques qu'ils
soient plus plus propre et c'est ça et
moi je prendre le libre marché va avoir
la solution il faut pas il faut pas
faire en sorte que notre mode de vie
change et qu'on taxe les gens ça
prendrait une taxe de 300 dollars la
tonne pour s'assurer qu'on respecte en
tant de paris iap un policier qui est
assez sérieux pour dire qu'ils vont
imposer trois cents l'heure la tonne
donc pour moi ils sont hypocrites
vous m'avez répondu quand je vous ai
demandé à ce que si vous étiez devenu
chef du parti conservateur auriez-vous
les mêmes politiques plus extrêmes
l'investissement exprès mais quand vous
dites tous ces gens qui manifestent qui
sont des propagandistes alarmiste j'ai
vu les images aujourd'hui oui partout
sur la planète des gens qui sont
réellement inquiet c'est vous qui avez
le pop et sont dans le champ nom moi ce
que je dis aux gens et ce que je déplore
c'est qu'on dise aux élèves de
manifester et de quitter l'école l'école
de colle de faire l'école buissonnière
parce qu'on leur fait peur autant de
panique regardez greta et greta nous dit
qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit on a dit
qu'on devrait panique et qu'on devrait
finalement indiquons devrait agir
conjugal où il m'a dit vous devriez
paniquer comme je fais et sentir la peur
que je sens on peut pas baser des
politiques publiques sur la panique
il faut avoir une discussion et c'est
pour ça que les gens de la gauche ne
veulent pas avoir de discussions ce
qu'ils nous disent et on panique il faut
réagir tout de suite moi je dis on
devrait réfléchir avoir des débats et
c'est pour ça que je suis bien heureux
de participer au débat parce qu'on va
certainement débattent d'environnement
au prochain débat avec les autres chefs
et j'ai une position guillaume lemans
différente parce que pour moi
l'environnement je termine là dessus il
faut faire des choses concrètes pour
l'environnement la ville de montréal la
ville de vancouver jette encore leurs
égouts dans le fleuve
ici à montréal dans le fleuve vit à
vancouver dans la mer via une usine de
traitement oui mais on peut améliorer on
est des choses qu'on peut faire il ya
encore des lacs sont pollués des
rivières qui sont pour lui des t5 sans
polluer dernière chose
concrètement c'est ma peau si vous dites
nous laissait entendre que vous n'êtes
pas le seul mais vous laissez entendre
que greta tandberg par exemple et
d'autres sont manipulés mais ce qui
serait manu pu manipuler par qui par les
oiseaux par l'air pur vous êtes qui
manipulerait les loeb est important vous
le savez monsieur bernier vous savez
c'est les pétrolières
c'est l'aider du lait les gens qui ont
un lourd poids économique cae et la baie
c'est pas les environnements dans les
écoutes et les radicaux
environnementalistes qui veulent qu'on
change le mode de villes qui veulent
nous imposer un mode de vie différent
la société évolue la technologie est là
les changements climatiques sont là et
on a des moyens pour s'assurer que l'air
et l'eau et ils soient plus pur et s'il
faut le faire mais actuellement c'est la
panique il a en moi je suis contre cette
manière c'est juste que je vous dis
immigration c'est très clair vous
proposez combès l'immigration canada est
ce que c'est parce que c'est radical pas
nécessairement c'est un débat est
derrière vous avez dit qu'on ne pouvait
pas parler de ces choses là je vous
signale qu'il ya une campagne électorale
au québec où on a parlé ouvertement de
changer le sma mais ces messages assez
mes opposants politiques qui faisait ça
monsieur trudeau a laissé sous-entendre
que si on agit pas dicter radical ma
question c'est pourquoi il faut bien
c'est selon
pourquoi il faut bien c'est parce qu'à
350 mille nouveaux immigrants par année
pour moi c'est des migrations de masse
pour moi c'est 350 1000 par année c'est
plus d'un million de personnes à chaque
300 350 mille nouveaux arrivants à
chaque année c'est la population du
nouveau-brunswick écosse en trois ans
est ce que je dis c'est qu'à 350 1000
immigrants par année par capita le
canada voit que pays qui vont recevoir
le plus d'immigrants que tous les autres
pays 2
occidentaux et donc et à 150 milles par
année par capita on veut recevoir le
même nombre d'immigrants légaux que les
autres pays les américains les français
etc
eh bien moi je veux une meilleure
intégration des immigrants comme m'a dit
vous n'avez parlé de la politique
provinciale
comme dit monsieur legault on veut
n'avoir - on veut s'en occuper mieux
ouais sur le gouffre remontée remarquée
tout de suite après une année puis
remonte au seuil qui avait puis c'est
pas dit qu'on va pas augmenter parce
qu'un pénurie de main-d'oeuvre vous le
savez oui c'est pour content que vous
dit content que vous le dites parce
qu'effectivement on urine madame oui
dans les 300 dinars actuellement il
compte des gens qui viennent ici pour
nous aider à gué a pu nourrir main
d'oeuvre seulement 26% des 310 mais les
migrants par année nous on veut ratio
plus élevé on veut 50% des nouveaux
immigrants qu'ils soient des immigrants
économiques une personne qui vient ici
parce qu'on a besoin de ses qualités de
son expertise
- dont donc moins globalement mais plus
d'immigrants économiques et on répond
aux besoins du québec
je sais ce qu'ils valent une fille
mercier votre candidate dans bruce et
jours au nouveau brunswick qui dit moi
le coach allait avec monsieur bernier en
politique c'est parce que je veux et je
cite je veut limiter la menace islamiste
mais quand je vous parlais de positions
extrêmes ses soeurs dont jour par ce
discours là qui jouent sur la peur des
gens
est ce qu'il ya une menace islamiste au
canada on joue pas sur la peur de
personnes comptant pour la question
devient une menace islamiste au canal à
ce qui me concerne a le droit à ses
opinions et ses soeurs chef moi je dis
il faut faire une différence regarde des
jeux sont l'ontario ce qui se passe
présentement est un parti politique qui
veut devenir un parti politique officiel
en ontario et prendre la charia donc il
ya des gens moi le radical islamique
radical islamique politique c'est pas la
même chose que les gens qui ce triptyque
défendre et prendre leur religion qui
prendre les musulmans les musulmans dans
notre pacte non non je salue même
s'ouvre et donc les gens font pas la
distinction c'est moi c'est l'islamisme
politique et en ontario il ya un parti
pour l'étirer mission
le laissez pas laisser croire je sens
que nous sommes envahis par l'islamisme
point de vue alors son point de vue
quand vous êtes dans votre parti ben oui
mais écoutez on laisse croire madame
grès torres croire que c'est la fin du
monde si on chante on traite pas les
changements climatiques aujourd'hui les
gens vont tout seul on parle
d'environnement on disait cette année
les grands médias disaient cette année
que les feux qui assure la planète
actuellement surtout au brésil ça s'est
jamais vu à travers le monde c'est la
petite masoni l'amazonie et cetera mais
la bbc a fait un bon reportage les feux
que les feux qu'on actuellement c'est
moins pire on avait des pires il ya
quinze ans elle le fait un reportage en
regardant les photos satellites
regardons les faits c'est 'qui en
amazonie rue des fruits de soirée mais
c'est pas les purs feu les pires feux de
forêts et si on écoute les nouvelles des
ponts pense que c'est les pires feu il
ya 15 ans j'en avais encore plus sur la
planète derrière je partage la bbc
chaîne part en tête parce que vous
exportez le style tram etc vous savez
bien non non non absolument pas vous
n'êtes vous pas dit ça d'ailleurs que
vous respectez vous d'envié que son
populisme c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
mais n'a absolument pas j'ai dit que je
faisais en fait de la politique
différemment je suis un politicien
populiste oui mais c'est un peu plus
intelligent on ne fait pas appel à
l'émotion des gens ont fait appel à leur
intelligence avec des politiques
publiques sont bâties sur des principes
la liberté la responsabilité le respect
et l'équité et tous nos politiques
prenaient tous nos politiques publiques
sont issus de ces principes là et il
faut expliquer à la population nos
positions et c'est ça qui est ça que
j'aime en politique je vous donne un
exemple parler de la gestion de l'offre
il ya trois ans était pas populaire mais
plus qu'on en parle de l'abolition du
cartel de l'upm et toutes ses populaires
si on a les mêmes idées et on veut en
débattre
parlant de la gestion de la fpt c'est ce
qui vous a fait perdre selon plusieurs
le plus de votes et vous auriez pu avoir
pour être chef du parti conservateur
en gros ça va pour faire perdre voici
maintenant c'est votre opposant
conservateur est pas un producteur
laitier
oui justement et s'est soldée bamboos il
est là pour défendre ses propres
intérêts dit qu'une il travaille avec
lupe en bosse moi je suis là pour
défendre l'ensemble des beaucerons
je souhaite que les beaucerons peuvent
payer la moitié moins cher pour leur
lait leur poulain leur l'économie pour
une famille beauceronne ça serait 400 $
par année je pense que c'est important
mais monsieur leroux veut travailler
avec lui payant et défendre son prix le
lâcher j'ai rien contre ça si tu donnes
c'est une larme
surhumaine quand vous défendre nos
privilèges mais c'est qu'on travaille
qu'on veut travailler pour les brosses
on devrait penser pour l'ensemble des
beaucerons est ce que j aux producteurs
laitiers je leur dit écoutez vous fait
de bons produits
vous devriez capable d exporter comme
les producteurs de boeuf comme les
producteurs de porcs qui exportent
partout ailleurs le pays à travers la
planète pardon j'aimerais bien ça que
les producteurs de lait de poulet 2
peuvent experts pour exporter en
abolissant ce quartier là ils vont
pouvoir exporter on va racheter leurs
quotas
il va avoir une période de transition
est passé en tout cas vous êtes
conséquent avec vous même parce que vous
n'avez pas changé d'idée
ce que je peux changer de mains si ça
peut vous faire perdre en bon ben on va
voir les beaucerons ont décidé ces
surdoses décidera en dernier jamais rien
et qui ont porté un petit mot parce que
l'oeil et je vous ai j'ai lu de trois
versions de ce l'avortement oui vous
vous êtes trop choix moi j'ai jamais
voté pour restreindre le droit à
l'avortement choix j'ai jamais fait si
jamais voter si vous appelez ça pour
choix oui j'ai jamais voté pour moi j'ai
jamais voté pour restaurer le droit à
l'avortement des femmes dans tous les
votes à la chambre des communes mais
vous souhaitez que le débat soit relancé
où l'on souhaitait un vote n'ont ainsi
jamais ici c'est ça oui merci de me
poser la question alors oui
effectivement y'a pas de quoi ce que je
souhaite c'est le parti populaire n'a
pas de position là dessus et donc les
époques elle c'est pas une question
notre campagne est orale on n'a pas de
plateforme là dessus puis si jamais il
un vote qui vient de n'importe quel
parti politique ou de n'importe quel
député ça se rendre votre livre à la
chambre des communes c'est ce que je
vois que vous avez voté contre comme
dans le passé je n'ai jamais à voter
effectivement beau restreint le droit à
l'avortement mais je pas entendu passer
je parlais visiteurs y est content je
voterai que selon les principes et les
valeurs comme donc pour le libre choix
comme moi et mes principes et valeurs
c'est berner on va suivre ça le soir en
beauce et ailleurs vos candidats merci
merci au revoir